bonsoir matteo ghisalberti merci
beaucoup avec nous sur rt france on a
entendu le président du conseil giuseppe
compter durcir encore davantage les
règles en italie est ce que c'est la
bonne voie est ce que évidemment il faut
prendre ces mesures
oui c'est une bonne décision
malheureusement elle est arrivée un peu
tard parce que les régions du nord de
l'italie les plus touchées en
particulier la lombardie avait demandé
des faveurs de fermeture il y a déjà
quelques jours est malheureusement
toujours des raisons politiques internes
gouvernement italien a préféré adopter
un schéma de commandes ira confrontation
politique quatre parties plutôt que
s'appeler c'est de trouver une solution
pourrait indiquer la propagation
je dois constater aujourd'hui que il ya
un petit signe d'espoir parce
qu'apparemment aujourd'hui à l'heure où
la registre pour la première fois une
petite baisse db c'est hier et 713
aujourd'hui 107 651 donc il ya eu une
toute petite baisse mais ont
naturellement c'est très très tôt et
trop tôt pour dire que l'épidémie est
terminée
ou alors on voyait un décalage la chine
a été la première touchée elle a pris
des mesures de confinement on voit
qu'italie s'achemine vers ces mesures et
la france aussi qui avec un temps breton
prend les mesures que l'italie prend
c'est un combat entre les scientifiques
et les politiques stars bradfer
finalement je ne sais pas ce que je
pense c'est que il faut agir vite que je
le dis tout simplement sur la base je
suis pas médecin je peux je n'ai pas de
prétention de donner des leçons à qui
que ce soit mais je dois constater tout
simplement que l'italien a perdu du
temps et ce qui est fait la différence
entre la situation italienne il y a
quelques semaines et celle princesse
d'aujourd'hui c'est que la france a à 10
ans un exemple
nature qui est justement celui de
l'italie est donc peut-être prendre de
décision dure et rapide permettra de
gagner chaque jour passé d'un digne des
mesures de confinement plus strictes
maintenant permettra de gagner un jour
plus tard de nouvelles vies de leurs
voitures des commerces ni et
naturellement des écoles etc
notre vie on le voit le conseil d'état a
rejeté un beau coup de deux
scientifiques et de personnes du secteur
médical en france avait demandé des
mesures de confinement total en dents
dans france le conseil d'état a dit non
c'est aux politiques de décider on a du
mal à comprendre pourquoi ce serait plus
le rôle du politique par rapport à aux
décisions des des fameux scientifique
qu'il consulte sans doute les politiques
sont là parce qu'on les a élus ils
représentent la nation et donc cela vaut
pour tous les pays démocratiques donc en
france de santé publique non oui
justement mais ce qui tranche le
toujours sérieux politique donc bien sûr
il doit faire appel à des experts en ce
cas ce sont les experts en santé mais
mais c'est les politiques qui doivent
prendre une décision parce que sinon on
devrait élire des médecins pour faire
gérer la le service sanitaire mais ça
marcherait bien d'ailleurs
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
politique en france où il n'y a pas un
confinement total certaines villes ont
pris des mesures de couvre-feu des
mesures qui finalement ne font pas les
mêmes partout
je pense que ce n'est pas mon dieu ce
n'est pas simple de gérer cette
situation ça je sais c'est sûr et c'est
très difficile pour chacun de nous parce
que nous sommes confinés
surtout si on a des enfants de personnes
dépendantes
c'est vraiment très compliqué mais voilà
chacun de nous malheureusement et
potentiellement porteurs de ces virus
chacun de nous
engendré la compliquer des complications
auprès des quelques uns
quelqu'un d'autre on sépare donc dans le
doute vraiment il faut respecter les
confinements et malheureusement ce n'est
pas le cas parce que il y à beaucoup de
monde par exemple qui ne resta pas la
distance de sécurité dans les
supermarchés tout simplement et c'est là
vraiment faire pour piéger le virus très
rapidement et puis les mêmes qu'on ira
le coût à payer est très lourd on voit
l'italie qu'est ce qui était en train de
faire ce pays qu'est ce qu'est en train
de vivre
et personnellement je voudrais pas que
la france figure alors on voit
l'allemagne elle qui n'a pas décidé de
confinement de sa population qui fait
confiance à sa population et est
justement au respect des règles c'est
une différence de mentalité entre les
pays vous pensez je ne sais pas ce qui
est certain c'est que même les italiens
qui souvent sont accusés d'être
considéré comme un peu indisciplinés
mais toutefois sans licence et suivre
les indications
mais si le gouvernement a pris ses
décisions sur demande des gens du nord
de l'italie
c'est aussi parce qu'il y avait encore
beaucoup de monde qui bouge et qui donc
était un véhicule de ce virus
après ce qui concerne l'allemagne il
faut dire que bon il ya des différents
points d'observation de la situation et
il ne faut pas oublier en tout cas que
avec le coronavirus on a signé l'arrêt
de mort de l'union européenne parce que
on a vu surtout depuis l'italie des pays
européens qui ont empêché ou qui ont
carrément séquestré matériel médical en
distançant dans ces moments là à
l'instant parce que bon ils ont mis deux
des contrôles douaniers
ils ont récente les exportations c'est
le cas de l'allemagne par exemple de la
pologne
justement avec les contrôles pionnier il
l explique cheikh a
même saisi des masques qui viennent est
de la chine et qui avait été offerte par
la chine à l'italie donc c'est là ça je
pense de la solidarité européenne dé
façon définitive et donc c'est très bien
aussi et certains pays ont décidé de se
recentrer
mais bon je pense que pour d'autres
c'est clair que l'union européenne a
vraiment un secteur très limité alors
les pays qui viennent en aide à l'italie
on l'a vu aujourd'hui il ya eu la chine
il ya également la russie cuba ces pays
là vont pouvoir apporter un peu de répit
à l'italie sans doute toutes les bonnes
volontés sont les bienvenues
et bien sûr on peut pas demander à des
pays qui sont sous le commandement sous
la menace
explosion de la contamination c'est le
cas de la france
on peut pas demander d'aidé un autre
pays parce que sinon ça serait comme
lire un conte poétique mais de là à
arriver même à arrêter d'aider du
matériel qui est vitale et qui
finalement peut servir aussi aux autres
supérieure ens pearl valley sens que si
un pays réussi à endiguer la propagation
du virus
vu que le virus passe des frontières
c'est dans l'intérêt de tout le monde de
réussir à juguler cette question
pour l'instant ce que l'on sait c'est
qu'on a vu c'est que le confinement
c'est la façon la plus efficace heures
merci beaucoup matteo ghisalberti
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france